no Lorimar avec which is good you know
that he is a senior fellow at Hudson
Institute and you know that he was
formerly a senior internationally policy
analyst at the RAND Corporation at least
until he had the effrontery to suggest
that our allies the Saudis might not be
holding up their part of the bargain he
has been a consultant to the French
Ministry of Defence and taught at the
Ecole de haut a tune Encino sosial in
Paris
he's a prodigious author many books and
lots of of articles and op eds but the
books include a French translation of
Clausewitz on war war in the 21st
century which is translated it which is
in both French and go figure in Chinese
the spirit of nations cultures and
geopolitics and fourth coming from
Hudson Institute the mind of jihad the
book that we will be discussing tonight
is an expanded version of the llegará
pray which was published in Paris last
year and the princes of Darkness is an
expanded and extended version of that
and I'm pleased to say that the princes
of Darkness has already been picked up
by three book clubs so it it pays
sometimes to go out on a limb we all
know the wrong as a an extremely
provocative thinker and an
unconventional thinker he combines in
his analysis a great variety of
disciplines and he he mixes them and
combines them in intriguing ways his
recent works have concentrated heavily
through the analytical filters of
anthropology of history and philosophy
and just an opportunity to read one of
these books
I recommend to each of you because of
the great synthetic and the great
greatly provocative style of the of the
language and the way that he finds his
way through these different disciplines
in unique and often challenging ways I
might add that he's an old friend he's a
very fine chef and a new father so all
of that should should recommend him to
you and I will now recommend him to you
and stand out of the way and ask Laura
maravilla to discuss the princess of
darkness Laura thank you Enders after
after this presentation I guess I should
remain silence not to lower the esteem
that you already have for me but now I'm
not going to do it I can't help I'll
talk a week ago or so Prince Saud
al-faisal the foreign minister of Saudi
Arabia explained on quote him we're
fighting as hard as we can against
terrorism I would dare anyone to say
that there is another country that it's
fighting terrorism as hard as we are
Luxembourg and Dora
San Marino I don't know maybe the Prince
the Prince actually called Colin Powell
no Colin Powell called the Prince three
years ago after I gave my infamous
briefing at the defense policy board at
the Defense Department to assure His
Highness the prince
these guys are princesses thousands of
princes that are what I said had nothing
whatsoever to do with American policy
and that it was decisively rejected by
the administration so our our the Saudis
fighting terrorism or not terrorism is
not just some killer throwing a bomb or
throwing himself as a bomb onto a target
terrorism is an integrated chain
it comprises the the financier the
logisticians the intellectuals the
predicator 's the books that are written
and that served to indoctrinate
brainwash kids into becoming killers
it's a long chain and I want to examine
with you some aspects some key aspects
of this chain and see if that chain
exists in Saudi Arabia which better than
proclamations will tell us whether or
not
Saudi Arabia is fighting as hard against
terrorism as Luxemburg San Marino and
Endora our Freedom House recently found
books with the seal of the Saudi
government distributed in mosques
throughout the u.s. full of incitement
to hate and calling for waging war
against the West Jews and Christians
this is to the point that the Senate
Judiciary Committee its head Arlen
Specter sponsored something called the
Saudi Arabia Accountability Act of 2005
the purpose of which is to hold Saudi
support for institutions that fund
trained insight and courage or in any
other way aid and abet terrorism and to
secure full Saudi cooperation in the
investigation of terrorist incidents at
hearings held by the Committee on
November 8th a week ago Nina Shaye
showed video clips that showed that had
Saudi clerics prominent ones in siding
over Saudi state television inciting
with words in the fight against infidels
throats must be slit skulls must be
shattered and quote on the official
Saudi TV IQR a prominent cleric Musa
Carney who is rather connected to I mean
his family has a lot of terrorists in it
said I'll quote him the uproar and the
chaos that we see today in the human
race the killing the acts of aggression
the rape the robbery and the disgrace of
Honor what causes this is that the
banners which are hoisted I are those of
the Jews the Christians and other
religions of and faiths and not the
better of
Islam we ask Allah to strengthen the
spirit of the jihad fighters in Iraq and
to help them against the enemies the
Jews and the Christians likewise are
emphasized that the jihad that the
Muslims are fighting in Iraq in order to
repel the enemy aggressor the Jews and
the Christians who are attacking land
and honor I emphasize that this jihad is
legitimate jihad jihad for Allah's sake
and it is considered defense of Muslim
countries their lands and their honor
the doubts that are raised against this
jihad are not correct and are out of
place this is a on state television in
Saudi Arabia in fact Saudi Arabia
continues to fund terror through such
organizations as the International
Islamic Research Organisation the world
Muslim League the World Association of
Muslim youth all of which well they're
not NGOs they are often called NGOs but
they are not because on their boards you
find Saudi cabinet members and princes
of leading princes of the royal family
for example Prince Salman half-brother
of King Abdullah full brother of late
King Fahad is known to control iro
distributions with an iron hand
according to the excellent expert
Matthew Leavitt of the Washington
Institute I'll quote em Saudi officials
have exhibited at a minimum a clear
pattern of tolerating funds earmarked
for extremist purposes for example one
Saudi official stated that a Saudi
organization created to crack down on
charities that fund terrorism has been
ineffective because it's personnel
doesn't want to uncover high-ranking
Saudis actively financing such charities
the Saudis have taken steps to combat
money laundering and freeze accounts
related to the September 11th
conspirators I would add that nothing's
been done against the September 12th
conspirators the September 13th 14th and
all the rest of it moreover this is a
Matt Levitt speaking again they recently
passed new regulations governing private
fundraising Saudis are now
courage to donate funds only to
establish groups operating under the
direct patronage of the royal family
aren't we breathing more freely buddy
ads unfortunately some of these approved
groups feature prominently on the US
terrorist lists very recently week ago
a deputy assistant secretary of the
Treasury Dan glazier said the u.s. is
deeply concerned whether the Saudi bans
on funding charities overseas has been
implemented and he mentioned
specifically III ro the world
association of Muslim youth the world
Muslim League so as far as funding
terror I'm afraid that the Saudis aren't
quite holding their end of the bargain
in August Oh President Bush reported
that King
then Crown Prince Abdullah had given him
given him strong assurances that the
funding would come to an end
this has not occurred now that's the
money what about what's happening in
Mainz because ultimately the money buys
the logistics etc but what is important
is what's in the mind of the killers
well they have been over the last years
very numerous fatwas authored by
prominent Saudi clerics encouraging
jihad against the US notably
in Iraq actually you know the sweet man
the new Saudi ambassador to the United
States Prince Turkey well Prince Turkey
Thanksgiving is coming I think we should
do something about that Prince Turkey
who just presented his credentials at to
a grateful State Department which has
never seen a an Arab Sunni tyrant they
didn't love a prince turkey called a war
in Iraq a colonial war now thank
goodness for such friends actually he's
a great fan of mine too in the fall of
2003 I as Anders mentioned I worked this
book in
the this princess of darkness is the
expanded English version of it a French
publisher had asked me to write it it
was called in the French the French
style is the next war meaning after Iraq
where where do we go so the prince
I learned guts got the book translated
privately translated from French into
Arabic two guys worked posthaste in
London when he was the Ambassador then
two to translate it and I'm sure the
book must have pleased him immensely but
not to the point that he would have the
gumption to go to Paris and sue either
myself or the publisher in point of fact
he did not but French libel laws though
not as favorable to authors in free
speech First Amendment as American laws
are sort of balanced it's difficult you
have if you're a plaintiff you have to
show malicious intent on the part of the
author
fortunately for His Highness Prince
Turkey British laws are far more lenient
in point of fact these are less majesty
laws where basically the plaintiff has
to prove that you know God himself
dictated these words and even I'm not
sure that God hasn't been indicted in
sentence by British Court for libel if
we read the Bible close enough I'm sure
some British courts would find it in
itself to to endure God so I had given a
long five page interview to the French
magazine Poli much about about this book
and in in the interview I said rather
unfriendly things concerning Saudi
Arabia are and the prince
his highness himself so as a result
pally much was sued in London now what
do you I mean this is a French magazine
sued for libel in London and now I said
the British libel laws
it cost a million pounds just to defend
you're going to put down a million a
million quid as they say down in order
to defend a libel suit and it cost 40
times more in London to defend a libel
suit than in Paris for example so the
publisher you know after originally they
were they were gung ho and then they
realized so they they gave up so as I
said prints turkey is very friendly to
me his media advisor is a man called
Jamaal khashoggi you may know the name
weapons corruption blah blah blah ah
so Jamaal Khashoggi had written some
really choice words with a kind of
courteous and refined culture that's
typical of the Saudi made media and the
nicest of all the names he called me was
a low-class prostitute so now you know
soldiers have ribbons for the campaigns
I have my little badges of honor and
this is one of the real nice one once so
anyway I said numerous fat words have
been issued by a bunch of prominent
Saudi clerics authorizing JIT amaizing
recommending jihad against America in
our Iraq as a result 100,000 Saudis are
presently in jail in Iraq in connection
with al-qaeda activities and 60 to 70
percent of the foreign fighters nabbed
in Iraq by the Iraqis and our troops are
salaries so there must be something
amiss there I just remembered that the
prominent the dominant tribe in Fallujah
happens to be a Wahhabi tribe which
makes certain events that occur they're
not entirely coincidental now what's
happening inside Saudi Arabia are we are
we improving is is the call for jihad
that was coming from the 50,000 mosques
of the of the kingdom is that call are
still are still being heard or has it
all changed well a last February
the Minister of Education who was a as I
understand a fairly decent character was
replaced by now King Abdullah by a
hard-line Mahadi
so if there's one direction this is
going it's not the right direction and I
hear the this week that a teacher Saudi
teacher by the name of Mohammed alharbi
was sentenced to 40 months in jail and
750 lashes now go ow
because seven nobody in the world could
survive 750 lashes for the awful crime
of having discussed in class the Bible
Jews and Christians not unfavorably so
the direction is not terribly good the
the apartheid system which rules Saudi
Arabia internally is is going on like
very recently there was a great first
done by this great liberalizing King
Abdullah a Shiite cleric was going to
speak on Saudi television that was a
great first for 250 years the Wahhabi
have made it a sports a national sport
of tribal sport rather to slaughter and
trample underfoot and Shiite they can
get their hands on so shy Hassan Mossad
sufferer was supposed to speak on Saudi
television for the first time and lo and
behold it was canned
he will not appear on Saudi television
and on July 15th about a hundred clerics
and judges and university professors and
leaders of the muta wine leaders the
religious police issued a statement on
the world historical problem of women
driving now with all due respect to the
ladies in this room it says something of
the state of the affairs in the kingdom
that this should be a major central
subject of polemic so anyway these
hundred enlightened individuals are
wrote enemies of Islam I'm quoting them
are seeking to destroy the great world
women have been given in Islam the
production
by corrupting them and hence corrupting
the Islamic world and who are these
enemies if you think that it's Jews
Christians and hypocrites you are right
but maybe you'd forgotten the hypocrites
so I'm glad to enlighten you on that on
that account now of course the Saudi the
Saudi government the Saudi state have
been attacked by terrorists ah that has
been used extensively or to tell us see
they are good people they are being
attacked by terrorists bin Laden doesn't
like them
therefore we should like them now one
has to say the Royals who are very very
very very soft targets I've never been
attacked once since one has looked at
what's happening in the kingdom or
outside the kingdom and if you want to
if you want to nab a Saudi prince what
you do go to London to some you know
strip joint luxury go to Marbella go to
Surrey or Kent go to Colorado to Aspen
soft targets not to speak of the palaces
and all the rest of it not none none of
them ever was attacked which you know
good for them uh but uh hint hint the
victims inside Saudi Arabia the victims
of terror are Americans Brits Lebanese
Christians other Arabs and low-level
Saudis so there again there's something
wrong in the way this is happening
there's been there have been terror
attacks in Saudi Arabia all the targets
are people that the jihad is usually
detest the Saudi jihadis so there's one
form of terror that the Saudi royals
disapprove sternly that's terrorism
inside Saudi Arabia against them there's
one type of terror that they love it's
terror in Iraq or in Israel and some
other places look
Venis I've done 40 or 45 radio talk
shows in the last few weeks and I've
learned to develop certain very quick
definitions and people ask me so how
would you define the Saudi royals I
always end up saying they are Taliban's
without oil while the Taliban's
with oil whereas the Taliban's are
Saudis without oil their stops the the
difference so one type of terror that's
approved it is fun and fine to kill our
children or Jewish children that's fun
that's great thought was fat was fat was
what is bad is a to dare touch the Saudi
royal family or rather its assets what I
would say therefore is that the
disagreement between the Saudi princes
and the laden is of the tactical order
the aims are essentially the same the
tactical difference is you've got people
who want regulated terrorism that's the
walls why because they have a country to
defend and then you have the other guy
the the lean and mean of fanatic you
know young Cassius has a mean and hungry
look
this is bin Laden so they don't have the
same short-term tactical objectives but
otherwise it's the same mind oh it's not
the same body some are large some others
are very lean but enough of that now
what's what's going to happen now in
Saudi Arabia oh if you if you read what
I don't want to attack other think tanks
in town I think that management of
Hudson would not be happy if I did that
some think tanks in town which are have
an abundant literature on the Middle
East and especially on Saudi Arabia
explain to us that there's a new king
it's a new dawn of Hope in Saudi Arabia
now yeah you bet he's 83 years old the
new king and he's been in power for 40
years plus
that's Abdullah ah who's been the head
of the Saudi National Guard for 42 or 43
years this is the most xenophobic the
most ritual grass
of part of Saudi of Saudi society this
is the the deep desert Bedouins who you
know who think that you know other
Sunnis are already dangerous not to
speak of others farther out so change
I think he's weird rearranging a number
of chairs on the deck uh and of course
the the chorus line of the PR firms next
Street on K uh are enthusiastic about
this new dong the freedom can you hear
the Tremeloes in their voices
now he's just done one thing he's
created a national security council
which he took away from Prince my F if
Prince Nayef is the guy who said that
September 11th had been done by the Jews
actually Abdullah said it too and Turkey
said it too and bombed arson so you know
they all said it basically but anyway uh
the NSC there was taken away from Prince
Nayef the Ministry of the Interior uh
and now there's a NSC with Prince Sultan
who is only seventy seven and uh his son
a band are who are graced Washington
until a few months ago with his a very
fat checkbook so can we expect change I
mean forget it in one word this is not
the team are to that's that's that has a
mandate for change now the one change
that's real is is oil at $60 a barrel ah
at that price you can buy so many more
people then you can buy a thirty now
that's a big difference so I do think
that the dynasty has bought some years
of survival
in the middle of an extremely precarious
situation where pressures internal and
external are converging on the the Saudi
Empire if you want it's like the
seventy-three oil crisis about ten
crucial years to the dying Soviet regime
likewise today for the for the Saudis
spray more cash
Moe tribes etc now of course when the
excellent Karen use States quote I salud
the kingdom's efforts to work with us to
combat terrorism it is a sad joke it is
a very sad joke I had said in July Oh -
when Richard invited me to create a
storm
defense policy board quote the Saudis
are active at every level of the terror
chain from planners to Finance ears from
kateri to foot soldiers from
audiologists to cheerleaders I see no
reason to retract half a word of this so
what's to be done
the Saudis got a pass for six decades no
matter what they did everything it was
it was fine it was fun you always had
Brent Scowcroft to explain that by
supporting sunni dictators we were
buying peace in his recent New Yorker
piece uh he said but the Sunni dictators
have bought us have given us 50 years of
peace not to describe the last 50 years
of in the Middle East as peace requires
an extraordinary imagination so I think
additionally that we are in a
slow-motion divorce from Saudi Arabia
but it's the kind of divorce where the
two parties are not you know it's not
Richard Burton and Liz Taylor throwing a
throwing all the all the dishes on the
floor it's the kind of divorce where
both parts I think I'm all right jack
everything's fine everything's normal so
you know the president will even hold
the hand of of Abdullah in Crawford but
in reality last year 70 Saudi so-called
diplomats actually jihadis with
diplomatic immunity had their immunity
revoked the FBI probably had to break a
few heads at State for state to to
consent but it happened we moved a lot
of our military assets out of
Prince Khalid airbase in Saudi Arabia
together because the Saudis were trying
their damndest to prevent us from
toppling Saddam so there's been it's a
slow-motion divorce but I think the
direction of the divorce is is quite
clear I think now as I did three years
ago that we should issue a very clear
list of demands to the Saudi to the
great reformer King Abdullah telling him
you have to put a stop a complete stop
and not a cosmetic one and we can verify
- incitement indoctrination propaganda
the madrasahs the books the Imams the
predicator is the sermons and all the
rest of it radio TV papers secondly
bring a toll and final end to all the
funding through the charities and the
pseudo NGOs since Saudi Arabia is
essentially a totalitarian country
nothing of importance occurs without the
Rose knowing about it or being party to
it so they shouldn't have too much
trouble finding shutting down these
things they'll be shutting themselves
down good men and then the the all there
the Saudi intelligence personnel that
was involved and the pseudo diplomatic
personnel has been involved in in terror
should also should also be shut down or
else then
Saudi Arabia should meet the full wrath
of the United States now don't these
guys sell us enormous amount of oil no
they don't or number one oil suppliers
the province of Alberta in Canada and I
don't think that there's a Canadian
jihad an Albertan jihad against the
United States I'm not saying that it's
something one should contemplate lightly
but I'm saying it is not this it is not
this absurd a choice that's presented to
us either we give a total pass to the
Saudi royals or it's going to be bin
Laden and if the choice is so presented
to you then you say oh my god after all
yeah
it's better to have these bastards
because at least they are our bastards
like samosa and I think this is wrong
I think that our there's a whole lot of
intermediate solutions including
answering as in London last week I met
some hijazi independence movement people
interesting interesting after all he
jaws was way before the Al Saud family
was around he jaws was led by a very
sophisticated merchant bourgeoisie that
was trading internationally so this is
the Shiites of Saudi Arabia I don't
think are too emotionally attached to
the Assad family so we could do all
kinds of things now one one last word
are concerning the way the Saudis react
to what I'm proposing as I as I've
mentioned the Saudi press has made me
something of a punching bag with all
kinds of nice epithets are added but a
year in the hospital I was invited to
come to Riyadh to speak at a big
international conference on terrorism I
received a letter from the of all people
for the chairman of the big Wahhabi
University in Riyadh so dear mr.
moravyetti blah Allah so I I answered
after asking a number of people in town
do you want to kill me already what do
you think they want so you know they
said they said well you know I'd be bad
for them they'd kill you while you're
there my wife said you know not for not
bad form you'd be dead all the same so
yeah so anyway I I sent a reply saying
all right I'll come I only want two
things VIP security protection and I
want to meet the crown prince and a
bunch of your top policymakers at that
point tall silence for several weeks and
then I receive correspondence I said
dear mr. Marathi we've been trying to
contact you for three weeks you bet
unfortunately we haven't succeeded and
therefore it is too late to have you at
the conference so what I was thinking is
that the guy who issued the invitation
the chairman of the University probably
want to see Prince Anaya for one
these guidance and the prints looked at
innocent you invited home the poor guy
is probably if they're salt mines in
Saudi Arabia I know where he is
thank you well without further ado let
me invite Richard Perle
for to come up here and share his
thoughts with you as LaRon has said
Richard is the person who got him into
all of this so he's had a long time to
think about the the kinds of arguments
that have that you've heard here today
and is one of the most Richard as we
know is one of the most seminal thinkers
on security in the Middle East and and
how we should be configuring ourselves
to deal with it so Richard may I give it
to you thank you very much I'm glad I
made it I just came back from from New
York I wanted to be here in part to say
that I think this is an important a very
important book and I hope it will have
the effect of encouraging a real debate
about the nature of the Saudi regime and
the u.s. relationship to the Saudi
regime I recall very well the wrong
making some of the points that are made
in the book at a meeting of the defense
policy board and the explosive nature of
the reports that followed were really an
indication of how little serious
analysis had been done of the regime and
of us-saudi relations as LaRon just said
for six decades we paid scant attention
to Saudi policies that that over time
were helping to create the very
difficult and dangerous situation in
which we now find ourselves indeed it is
one of the great intelligence failures I
think of
this century in the last that the rise
of extremist institutions around the
world funded and inspired culturally and
intellectually by the lobbies of Saudi
Arabia went so unremarked I probed this
a little bit when I was in the closer to
government than I am today and asked a
succession of directors of Central
Intelligence whether at any time while
they held that post they were aware of
any effort to place in front of the
president the the warning signs that one
would have thought normal as we observed
the rise of extremist institutions
around the world
the madrasahs the pseudo NGOs and the
like and the answer I am now quite sure
was no at no time was any American
president apprised of the danger that
was that was taking shape this seems to
me a far larger intelligence failure
than then the failure to anticipate the
details of September 11 because it was a
huge and highly visible trend over many
years and our crack intelligence
institutions the CIA in particular just
missed it completely they missed it in
part I believe because the Saudi regime
has been extraordinarily skillful a
scale much assisted by large quantities
of money in fact if the money's
sufficient you probably don't have to be
all that skillful it has skillfully
created an image and impression of Saudi
Arabia in part by buying or at least
renting virtually every US government
specialist on the subject of the nature
of the Saudi regime as they have left
government service and not only that
they've made it perfectly apparent
people in government service who deal
with Saudi Arabia and indeed often with
the region they have made it apparent to
them that when they leave government
service there will be opportunities for
them it's corrupt
it's a suborning of American officialdom
and I think if we were to compile a list
of the several hundred Americans who
have have served in in Saudi Arabia in
various capacities have been employed by
the US government to advise us on how we
should think about the Saudis how we
should understand the nature of the
relationship between us I believe you
would find that a very high percentage
of them earn their living from a
continuing relationship with Saudi
institutions after they have left
government this needs to be investigated
and investigated thoroughly
I wish Patrick Fitzgerald if he goes on
to another intensive investigation will
focus on something like that which is
immense importance Bernhard Lewis wants
in trying to help us understand the
impact of the Wahabis said imagine that
the Texas branch of the KKK had at its
disposal the oil revenues of the state
of Texas early in the century would the
KKK have disappeared as in fact it did
or would it have established itself in
in quite different ways and and I think
the answer is that the vast amounts of
money that have been spent supporting
extremist institutions have had their
effect and they've had the their effect
all over the world and that money
continues to do what it is done all
along there are those of you who know
Steve Steve Emerson will know of his
work on extremist institutions in
in the United States and elsewhere I've
heard Steve say that he's had
conversations with with Muslim middle
Americans who have complained about what
was being preached on Fridays in mosques
in the Midwest only to be told that if
they didn't like what the Imam had to
say they should raise the money and hire
their own Imam because the Imams are
largely paid by the government of Saudi
Arabia or institutions closely
associated with the government of Saudi
Arabia and in in frustration because the
Muslim community America is not a
wealthy community devout Muslims have
accepted the reality that that their
religious environment and culture is
dominated by Saudi money and Wahhabi
thinking it's a it's a threat it's a
fundamental threat it's an even more
fundamental threat in my view than the
individual terrorists who have been
spawned out of that out of that
environment because it is it is
widespread and is persistent and we need
to do something about it and Iran is
quite right we won't do anything about
it until we accept that the Saudi regime
is both responsible and capable of
curtailing this activity and he's quite
right to observe that it is a
totalitarian state after all and if they
wish to curtail it they can do so I sat
in a meeting with one Saudi official who
said well unfortunately once money
leaves the kingdom we have no control
over it and even if that's true by the
way
money doesn't leave the kingdom without
the approval of Saudi government
institutions so there's a great deal
that they could do to curtail this if
they were willing to do so but instead
of acknowledging that there's a problem
that needs to be addressed they deny the
problem they deny it officially at
level and we for reasons that I think
are short-sighted have chosen to accept
those denials rather than precipitate
the the crisis the confrontation that
would inevitably result from demanding
an end to the submission of extremism
around the world and I very much hope as
I said at the outset that this book will
stimulate the sort of discussion that
will make it difficult for for us to
continue the policies of the past which
were to acquiesce in what the Saudi
regime has been has been doing and even
worse to pretend that things are getting
better because there's no evidence that
things are getting better we have time
for a few questions let me invite both
of our speakers to circle the mic and
I'll stand over here and try to direct
traffic right here please identify
yourself and speak up please so that the
c-span mics can pick this up
my name is Kamran beging I want to point
to a different area of the problem and
as the universities having just been
recently in universities the funding of
these Islamic study centres and the
professors who teach there some of the
professors are afraid of talking the
truth or discussing anything that is not
politically correct and if the
universities are developed very
important institutions of this country
for the free thought and education if a
professor is worried that he might lose
his livelihood is there anything that
can be done in the university areas or
investigate the funding and do not allow
for them to take over our universities
also we're fortunate to have in the room
Martin Kramer who's written an entire
book on this subject
it's called ivory towers in the sense
and it makes the point that middle east
are our balaji aslam ology in this
country in academia is an unvarnished
disaster intellectually it is the
the the sons of michel foucault and
eduard side its violently anti-american
its violently upon that Middle East
Studies Association which is like the
the guild of the anti Americans in
Middle East Studies and they've
perverted these studies to the point
that it's essentially a recoverable
there's this once come in front of of
ours to whom I was asking what should we
do with the CIA there's a big problem
that friend said well let's put some
barbed wire around Langley to prevent
them from coming out and I would say
perhaps we should do the same thing
around John Esposito Center at
Georgetown countless others just prevent
them from coming out send food in there
you know because we're nice people but
if I could just add this this creates
another and I and I think Lauren's
assessment is is right this creates
another problem because it is finally
dawning on on the CIA and some other
intelligence organizations that we have
been woefully ill-equipped to deal with
Islamist radicalism in part because we
don't have people who have this language
culture historical skills and so they
have resolved that we'll fix that
problem we will now go out and and and
we're pretty good at fixing problems
like that and we we found tens of
thousands of people to study Russian and
and in Russian history and Russian
culture and now we're going to do the
same thing I'm quite sure with respect
to the threat that we all know we face
from Islamist extremism but
unfortunately if we turn to the
educational institutions that are
capable of producing scholars in these
areas we're going to encounter the
problem Laurent has as just described so
it's it's a real dilemma we need people
who understand the region but the
institutions for training them
are already pretty far gone very very
I'm sorry it it no way me everything
completely standard
no big Tom's that's not okay
it is okay how any Emeryville publicly
standard spoke before about morning the
Saudis that they look like face the full
wrath with the United States I'm
wondering if you can tell what form you
do in picture this room graph is taking
and well then you also said we shouldn't
of the back away from creative crisis I
grew much of how you thought that crisis
might play itself out I think the the
royal family understands the fragilities
in in a society with a very rapidly
expanding population immense disparities
in material well-being deep historical
and geographic divisions it is in short
a society that is vulnerable to
destabilization they know that we should
know that - they have counted I think on
on are not taking any action that would
destabilize the kingdom in part because
of the sense they have helped to create
Saudi Arabia as an ally and friend it's
in part because I think they have
assumed that the alternative the the
view that the alternative is bound to be
worse is bound to be a bin Laden will
cause us to show great restraint and
regard the stability of the kingdom as
an
an asset that's what Brent Scowcroft
thought it was probably still thinks it
is so it's not easy to persuade them
that our interest in the stability of
their reign is rapidly declining if they
ever became persuaded of that I'm quite
sure they have enough respect for our
ability to destabilize they're there
they're quite fragile Kingdom and would
become a good deal more amenable to our
concerns so I would put it to them very
clearly the continuing subvention of
extremism around the world means that it
is no longer in the interest of the
United States that you remain in power
and if you look at simple things like
where the oil is and who benefits from
its production you can see the the basis
for what should give them an awful
fright and I would hope that at some
point we would privately convey the
message that as we lose interest in the
stability of your regime you'd better
watch out and I think we'd have a better
dialogue with them after that opening
conversation yes last week as I
mentioned the Senate Judiciary Committee
was holding hearings on lots of things
that are wrong with Saudi Arabia the day
before the night before the Department
of State informed the committee that
nobody would be coming from States to
testify and as I understand the Saudi
embassy was involved in massive lobbying
to have the hearings cancelled
altogether and certainly to have nobody
from the State Department there now if
we have diplomats who consider that
using a feather to hit any Saudi is
already tantamount to an act of war the
idea of putting pressure on the Saudi
regime
becomes outlandish uh so uh there are
intermediate forms of steps between the
feather and the nuclear weapon we all
need to occupy the oil fields tomorrow
morning and wait for tomorrow afternoon
ah they are lots of intermediate steps
and we should as any normal state as any
American government should do think okay
these people are doing lots of things
that are inimical to us what other means
that are appropriate to put pressure on
them without necessarily uh you know
calling a norman schwarzkopf back out of
retirement and telling you this time
south no not necessarily but we can do
lots of things we haven't even begun
that's the problem is ing I am with the
National Union for democracy in Iran
first of all I'd like to commend you for
your presentation I really enjoyed it
my question to you is as you do know
Saudi Arabia obviously they're pursuing
a certain goal towards this terrorism
support of terrorism financially Islamic
regime of Iran does the same thing in
your view are these folks are simply
supporting the same goal are they after
same goal are they working against one
another what do you think works for
thank you my friend marking the lien has
drawn a comparison between international
terror and the Mafia families in New
York City you know they spend their time
killing one another with gusto but when
the feds show up they all gang up now in
1949
I believe no forty forty seven one of
the founders of the most extreme terror
in Iran and a cohort of the then young
Ayatollah Khomeini called navab Saif Ali
went to Cairo to meet Hassan al-banna
the founder
of the Muslim Brotherhood and they
didn't like each other much because you
know each of them is like trotskyist you
know but they didn't like each other
much but like the Mafia family families
in New York they made a deal so the same
could be said about like a number of
years ago rasaan Johnny
the terrorist came to Riyadh and made a
deal with the Saudi terrorists I mean
the royal family and from then on
instead of Imams preaching the
systematic slaughter of Shiites every
hour it was only every second hour which
was you know great a great turn uh and
some cooperation was made notably with
the idea of turning to the Americans and
say woohoo see you're trying to put
pressure on etc uh this has just come to
an end actually with the the the
murderous fool that's not the president
supposedly the president of Iran and the
the and King Abdullah these the these
two seem to be back in their you know
both of them want if there's only one
crocodile that can that can go in the
waters of the Gulf over here
[Music]
hi I'm Rafael with with respect to Saudi
countermeasures to American pressure I
was wandering through familiar with what
Gerald Posner wrote in his book about
the possibility that Saudi Arabia
tweaked the oil fields with radiological
devices or Saudi efforts to acquire
nuclear weapons from Pakistan or from
other third party countries it seems to
me it seems to me that you know there's
there's this gangster who's just
ransomed the whole crowd in some
situation and he says don't touch me I'm
going to commit suicide you know let
them say that it's an amusing thing but
look we've we've had enough of these
Saudi countermeasures it's called
terrorism
it's called jihadi terrorism that's what
the Saudi counter measures are we've
suffered the full brunt of these counter
measures already any of these in these
characters say we are going to slide our
own throat shatter our own skulls to
spite you say well gentlemen please go
ahead I don't think the Saudis rely on
measures of that nature to protect
themselves I think they rely instead on
having created and sustaining the
impression that American and Saudi
interests are so closely aligned that
that countermeasures are unnecessary
because we are their natural friend and
Ally it's why they have reproduced I
don't know how many millions of copies
of the famous photograph of Roosevelt
and and the King you see it in every
Saudi publication practically every
month they haven't been confronted with
American measures that wouldn't that
would require them to look for
countermeasures because we have we have
been so willing to accept the
proposition that there that they are
really a friend in LA
just asking closing each of you thinking
of the downside scenarios with you
you've painted for us
what could Saudi Arabia look like 20
years well if if the current birth rate
continues and I imagine it would be
somewhere around 35 or 40 million
million people that that may be a slight
exaggeration but it's been growing it I
believe it's the largest birth rate
certainly in the Arab world and maybe in
the world if if oil prices remain high
over a sustained period of time I think
they will find it a lot easier to deal
with what inevitably is is likely to be
the instability of the the MAL
distribution of wealth in the country
most of Saudi Arabia is relatively poor
and I don't believe that can go on
forever that the Saudis greatly fear
success in Iraq and they fear it because
they believe that a democratic Iraq and
Iraq that is providing a decent life for
its people that is predominantly Shia
will pose a threat to them and they have
a long list of ways in which they would
feel threatened not least of which
because of the the power of the example
to the shia of saudi arabia for example
who happened to live where the oil is so
they they're very fearful about their
own their own future which is why so
much of the money is offshore when when
the saudis by Citibank it's not because
they are so confident that that it will
be there for them in Saudi banks I think
this is a the the House of Saud at this
point is is thinking only narrowly of
its own own survival and I believe
they're alarmed they quite
understandably try to exude exude
confidence but the signs are there that
they're troubled about their future and
they should be so I I would not invest
in Saudi Arabia today but then the
Saudis don't invest in Saudi Arabia
either if a few policies create
destruction if your policies create
destruction not only within your own
country 60% of the doctorates awarded by
Saudi universities are in Islamic
Sciences and it's really difficult to
operate an oil well with a doctorate in
Islamic science which is why they have
to rely on foreign slaves or glorified
foreign slaves technicians and so on to
run most of what works in Saudi Arabia
if you if you create a nothing that has
to do with the sources of wealth and
prosperity
if you don't educate people if you
decree that one half of society is only
good for Reproductive purposes it's
actually six to seven children per woman
per hour fertile period so this is I
think only Gaza
is is higher if you create watch not
only in your own country but your Creed
your ideology is to create rot elsewhere
and everywhere to make the whole world
look like you which is what this the
Wahhabi and the Saudi grand design has
been an is this is what King Faisal
undertook ah you know he was the guy who
is distributing a copy of the protocols
of the Elders of Zion to every single
one of his visitors so if you are if you
create that rut of Alex Alexei F has
shown the impact of sorry
we're buying Pakistan over a period of
30 years
Pakistan is essentially the only country
in the world where literacy rates
dropped literacy rates in black Africa
for women are higher than they are in
Saudi Arabia or in Pakistan for that
matter so if your Creed generates rot
corruption destruction and fails to
build whatever it is that is necessary
for the survival the maintenance of
society doctors engineers all the
resting people that sweep the floor and
that are not Filipinos because this is
against honor then and all the rest of
it you are preparing a formatively
troubled future in fact the formatively
trouble future is here except that right
now $60 a barrel for oil allows other
Saudis to paper over or to to buy time
to buy people to buy people that sweep
the floor and and all the rest of it so
I think that Saudi Arabia has poisoned
our the Middle East remember when uh
Sadat went to Jerusalem there was the
greatest chance for peace in the Middle
East and it was King Faisal who led the
charge to prevent that from happening
getting the the Syrians and all the the
rejectionists behind lined up behind him
Saudi Arabia is single-handedly
responsible for very much of all the
conflicts that have paci
brent scowcroft bloodied and destroyed
the Middle East and when you breathe
attack dogs so much the attack dogs
sometimes turn into wolves and this is
what has been happening and this what
increasingly will be happening the only
difference in in time are is a function
of the amount of money that the Saudi
Worlds can apply to buying people so
three years